foreign
let's slow things down a bit and take
notice of the world right beneath our
feet in these miniature environments
vast dramas unfold often without us ever
realizing it but what if we could become
part of these sagas
in the Pikmin series you play as a
character under two centimeters tall and
experience a tiny yet Rich ecosystem
from the ground level and though the
Pikmin universe is more stylized than
some it's surprisingly complex lore
makes it ideal for study so let's shrink
down and see the world from A New
Perspective
in a flash of light or ship arrives
PlanetSide this is World
pnf404 though we would know it as planet
Earth but this is not the Earth of today
humanity is gone and in its place
strange new orders of Life have emerged
we are a very tiny Explorer from a
distant planet it is our job to catalog
this world a daunting task considering
its many dangers
fortunately we are not alone in our
Endeavor this is a Pikmin a Red Pikmin
specifically these friendly local life
forms will help us uncover the mysteries
of this planet but what are Pikmin it's
a question we can't answer right away
for their biology is so bizarre it will
take time to formulate a theory let's
start with what we do know about Pikmin
Pikmin work together like ants or
termites they're usocial able to divide
up their labor to benefit the whole
while one group of Pikmin is defending
from a predator another might be
collecting resources or even building a
simple structure we also know that
Pikmin are unusually strong able to
carry objects much larger than their
bodies ants are capable of similar Feats
of impressive strength relative to their
size where Pikmin differ from familiar
life forms is in the reproduction Pikmin
are born from a strange globular plant
Nick named in onion the onion will
periodically release seeds into the air
which develop underground into adult
Pikmin it's such an unusual process that
we'll need to know more about their
world before we can understand it
the first region we've landed in is the
sun speckled Terrace lit by gentle
dappled Rays this area seems peaceful at
a glance but there are many hungry
mouths here these are bull borbs a
member of the grub dog family bulborbs
come in all shapes and sizes but are
united in their bottomless appetites one
of the most successful orders on the
planet bullworbs have conquered all
manner of environments in filled all
manner of niches The Peculiar whiptong
bowl borb for example has a feeding
method similar to an anteater able to
slurp up multiple targets with its long
sticky tongue we are fortunate to have
Pikmin on our side to help keep these
beasts at Bay but bullborbs are far from
the only danger these are fiery blow
Hogs creatures with poor manners and hot
tempers when threatened they can expel a
volatile phosphorus compound from their
snouts which combusts immediately upon
contact with the air this is where Red
Pikmin come in handy as flame-proof
cellulose In Their Skin makes them heat
resistant all the same it's best we give
blow Hogs a wide berth
more extreme life forms await us
underground in the old Caverns beneath
the Terrace unique Subterranean species
have emerged like the snowy blow Hogs
unlike their fiery relatives they prefer
to cool things down instead of heating
them up able to expel a compound similar
to dry ice from an internal cold Sac
Tusk blow Hogs forego the complex
chemistry of their siblings altogether
in favor of the simpler strategy of
running head first into prey these caves
are also home to the unpleasant sheer
grubs creatures that emerge from the
ground in droves like Pikmin there are
many specialized types of sheer grubs
with some possessing wings and others
long snouts ideal for spearing prey and
they have a nasty habit of swarming to a
human-sized life form these insects
would be little threat but this is a
world for the bugs now back on the
surface Flint beetles descendants of
modern Beatles and electrolids
descendants of butterflies thrive in
large numbers from her new scaled down
perspective these familiar species have
a newfound grandeur it is often our
Viewpoint that defines our surroundings
the sunspeckled Terrace seems to be the
remains of a small garden but navigating
it feels like crossing a vast
mountainous terrain it makes me think
more about my own perspective
there's a creek near the place where I
grew up I went for a walk there the
other day and as I walked I stopped at
random points and stuck my camera on the
ground it was awkward at first but it
made me realize something there are a
lot of bugs out there and yeah everyone
knows there's lots of bugs out there I
knew there's lots of bugs out there and
yet it still felt so different to
actually see them all I passed so many
bugs in the first few minutes it made me
wonder how many Hidden Worlds I walked
past every day
like the blossoming Arcadia another
micro ecosystem in Pikmin it appears to
be the remains of an old playground but
like the Terrace this ordinary Place
becomes a perilous expanse due to our
tiny lens fortunately the yellow Pikmin
are here to give us a helping hand their
bodies are naturally resistant to
electric currents able to withstand
shocks like certain species of catfish
and it's a good thing too because many
species in the Arcadia pack a serious
electrical punch this unusual specimen
is the bearded amp rat though
non-threatening when calm these
territorial creatures will sometimes rub
the hair on their face to generate a
formidable electric field the yellow
pikmen however are unimpressed by the
voltage
leaves fall in more peaceful regions of
the playground but bump into certain
leaves and you might be surprised these
are skitter leaves creatures that panic
and live up to their name when poked
because they often camouflage in a group
waking one skidder Leaf can start a
chain reaction that causes the entire
colony to panic perhaps it's kindest to
Simply watch our step
a species that will not extend this
courtesy to us is the yellow Wally hop a
rather rotund member of the amphi tuber
family they possess the rather rude
instinct to crush smaller life forms
will have to move fast to stay alive
fortunately we can catch a ride on a
furry companion this is Ochi a loyal
canine seemingly distantly related to
the dogs of Earth we don't know much
about his biology but I really like Ochi
Ochi is a very good boy
I'm less fond of the waddle quaff these
feathered life worms use their
over-developed respiratory muscles to
suck in large volumes of air through
their beaks an effective method of
feeding if a frustrating one to be on
the other end of but it's better than
facing down the Spear of a joust Mite a
burrowing insect joust mites are quite
proficient at spearing anything that
disturbs their Slumber clean through
including multiple targets should the
need arise it's a behavior similar to
the swooping snitch bug who will snatch
up multiple Pikmin and burrow them back
in the ground and if these fluttering
pests aren't enough to demonstrate the
Newfound might of insects the
bioelectric anode beetles of the caves
certainly are these insects can connect
with each other to create a discharge
too powerful to withstand only your
trusty yellow Pikmin or up to the task
but there are some challenges even
yellow Pikmin are not up for these
hopping fledglings are Downy snag grits
and probably don't seem like a
significant threat but they are only
babies and their parent is close by from
the ground emerges a colossal burrowing
snagrit this bird has converged upon the
niche of an ambush Predator their
mobility and sheer size make them the
Tyrant rulers of the blossoming Arcadia
perhaps this region simply isn't worth
the risk
maybe we'll have better luck on the
coast based on the name alone the Serene
Shores seem quite peaceful there's just
one problem ordinary Pikmin can't swim
we're going to need some kind of
specialist the blue Pikmin will be the
perfect lifeguards thanks to a
mouth-like gill membrane these Pikmin
can breathe underwater and are ready to
tussle with all manner of Aquatic Life
they're the ideal allies for this watery
ecosystem
skimming on top of the water is a
graceful Skeeter skate likely descended
from pond skaters Skeeter skates use
hydrophobic hairs on their feet to
remain on top of the water they store
water in a sack above their heads which
they'll regurgitate if we get too close
but it's better to be spit at than eaten
whole water dumples or unassuming purple
blobs with ravenous appetites their
behavior makes more sense when you
consider their closest relative is the
terrestrial bulb orb yet their appetite
seems almost quaint compared to the
peckish aristocrab while these
Crustaceans begin their life as Tiny
nuisances they soon grow into full-sized
intertidal Terrors an unfortunate
creature for those who enjoy long walks
on the beach and aristocrabs aren't the
only crustacean to look out for hermit
craw mads or Ambush Hunters that will
Rush at sources of movement from their
burrow before awkwardly wobbling back
underground a descendant of the hermit
crab crawmads have lost their shells
entirely and as a result are not the
bravest creatures here on the coast if a
crawhead fails in their initial attack
they will often shamefully Scuttle away
in defeat
other Ambush Predators have a less
subtle but form more destructive
approach orrut Kanan larva will
regurgitate large stones from their
gullet to flatten enemies they feed on
minerals to support the bacteria in
their gut a behavior analogous to
certain types of shipworms that consume
Limestone for the same reason a
questionable diet but an unquestionably
effective offensive tactic
not every animal on the Serene Shores is
quite so hostile puckering blinnos are
relatively peaceful creatures that swim
in schools beneath the surface pearly
clam clamps are another seemingly calm
semi-aquatic species but trigger their
snapping mechanism and you'll find
there's more to these clams than meets
the eye clam clamps are the ultimate
patient Hunters using their pearls as
bait to ensnare unlucky prey there
proved some Treasures just aren't worth
it
there's a region of the Serene Shores
that appears to be an abandoned aquarium
here you can encounter jelly floats
strange floating life forms that can
hover likely due to some internal gas
bladder yet while one's focus should
definitely remain on these Giant
floating Predators when I encounter them
I keep thinking about the surrounding
aquarium how uncanny it is that an
ecosystem is formed around this
abandoned place I have a similar
experience facing down the crusted rum
Pub the apex predator of its environment
this giant his poor eyesight and charges
blindly at any potential meal not a
creature to face while distracted yet
while evading this Goliath I found
myself once again transfixed by the
surroundings the rumpup seems to make
its home in an abandoned sand castle
like the aquarium here the remnants of
the past Define the present the same can
be said for most of the environments in
this game the shape of each ecosystem
determined by junk Humanity left behind
without a second thought
the landscape of the creek from my
childhood is marked by similar relics
plastic calves and broken bottles lie on
the banks I did my best to clean up the
area although more trash will certainly
come the creek itself isn't even a
natural stream it's all runoff from a
drainage pipe human overflow changes the
shape of micro environments like this
one all the time despite most people not
even knowing they exist
nowhere in Pikmin is Humanity's
influence more present than the next
region which takes place entirely within
an abandoned human home a unique
ecosystem with unique life the mighty
purple Pikmin are going to be of
particular help here as man-made
obstacles can be crushed under their
considerable bulk on the floor of the
household strange creatures Teeter about
these Oddities are called bread bugs and
live up to their names with bodies that
resemble well bread bread bugs can be
seen dragging shiny objects to Safe
locations perhaps due to some nesting
Instinct the real mystery however is why
any species would evolve to look like a
common food item the giant bread bug
subspecies looks even more like a
delectable loaf deepening the mystery
considering that camouflage is typically
a strategy to avoid getting eaten it's
probable that the bread bug's
resemblance to food is just a
coincidence
another culinary creature oozes across
the floor the sun squish resembles a
fried egg yet is actually a kind of
proto-chordate a type of invertebrate
though carnivorous this is one egg
that's not too difficult to scramble
but you're the one more likely to get
scrambled if you start a fight with a
mammoth snoot whacker this species
Sports a tough exterior shell to deter
Predators but if they still don't get
the message the snoot whacker can wind
up their trunks for a devastating strike
when a species asks for privacy it's
best to respect their wishes
in the Plumbing Systems below this house
a secondary ecosystem thrives this
environment is home to creatures like
the prickle puff a puffer fish-like
animal with toxic spines luckily ice
pikmen can help keep us from needing to
get our feet wet these Pikmin can freeze
bodies of water creating a walkable
surface in-game scientists assume these
creatures are made entirely of ice I
think it's more likely they have
biological components that let them
expel of freezing chemical mixture much
like a snowy blow hog although we still
need to learn more about Pikmin in
general to formulate a proper hypothesis
regarding their biology with ice Pikmin
in hand we'll make the acquaintance of
the hydro dweevel these crab-like
insects have a natural instinct to hide
under human objects the emergence of
such a behavior across all the Weevil
subspecies speaks to the impact
Humanity's debris has had on
evolutionary processes
but other creatures carry things for a
more Sinister reason the Gill demand we
possesses a sweet smelling crystalline
growth on their back to attract prey and
while juvenile Gil demand wheeze have a
somewhat limited appetite the adult
guildamander is prepared to ask for
seconds the vast growths on their back
combined with the anglerfish lights on
their heads mean that even the weariest
prey can be pulled in by their display
yet there is one species so wary not
even a gill demander could entice it
although that doesn't mean this cautious
creature is defenseless The Scorch cake
is one of the stranger life forms of the
Pikmin World these molten discs might
not look like an animal at all but they
are actually a type of mollusk a
connection that is more readily apparent
when they extend their periscopic stalk
eyes Scorch cakes create fire through
oils secreted from their shells a
strategy similar to the pyroclasmic
slooch a species of terrestrial snail
that might be the Scorch cakes close
relative though slouches have abandoned
the shells of their cousin they flash
bright colors to ward off any predator
not deterred by their scorching Trail
perhaps the most well-defended creature
of all is the porcupquillion these spiny
goliaths are among the most formidable
creatures in this entire region able to
fire off spines at an alarming rate if a
poor quillian runs out however they must
Retreat until their spikes are able to
regrow such a process expands
considerable energy and means the porky
quillian is always searching for its
next meal
since we don't want that to be us we'll
try our luck in the backyard a region
known as Giant's Hearth and right away
it's clear that this area is the wrong
Locale to seek Sanctuary bull Bears or
Bowl board relatives that are even more
aggressive than their cousins will need
some particularly tough Pikmin to Brave
this ecosystem
and it's difficult to get tougher than a
rock Pikmin these Stoney fellows are so
strong they Converse directly through
crystalline walls but how does an
organism Made of Stone function in-game
text implies The Rock pikmin's heart
exterior is actually just an outer shell
of inorganic material that a smaller
life form exists within and when you
consider that many modern organisms have
shells made of rock hard calcium
carbonate such an adaptation doesn't
seem so far-fetched but a tough shell
won't do you much good against a bloom
cap blister these hungry mollusks
constantly probe with their feeding
tendrils their smaller cousins the Toady
bloisters seem less threatening at a
glance but looks can be deceiving this
is one species that has changed
radically from its ancestors
other organisms have changed little over
the eons arachnodes are spider
descendants that remain just as skilled
as their ancestors able to sense food at
any point in their webs
underground little understood arthropods
called shutter chalks collect shiny
crystals these crystals have useful
properties and winged Pikmin will help
us transport them they may be small but
Wing Pikmin are deceptively strong this
doesn't seem impossible considering that
bees can haul up to 91 percent of their
body weight in nectar alone yet it does
show that the world of Pikmin still
holds many Secrets deeper underground we
can at least answer the mystery of where
bulb orbs come from they appear to begin
their life as Tiny larva utterly
defenseless without an adult but an
adult is close by this is an empress
bowlbacks a grub dog with a massively
enlarged egg Sac for bearing children
like the queen of an ant colony when
threatened this Monarch will try to
crush opponents with its sheer bulk
rolling directly over them but left to
her own devices the empress bowlbacks
prefers to peacefully snooze in fact
most of the creatures in this game seem
calm until the player stumbles by
I loved looking under rocks as a child
getting a glimpse of the insects in
their natural state except I wasn't
seeing them in their natural state not
really I was seeing their panic mode
after their home had been disrupted to
get nature to do what I wanted I acted
less like an observer and more like an
instigator and the same thing happens
when you play Pikmin you might have
noticed throughout this video that lots
of creatures require a treat to motivate
them into doing something interesting
for the camera you're not really
connecting with the ecosystem you're
more pushing it into doing what you want
of course sometimes the ecosystem pushes
back explore at night and we'll find
familiar locations made eerie and
unsettling in animals becoming more
aggressive your only hope is to make an
alliance with the mysterious glow Pikmin
who seemed to be ghosts like the in-game
encyclopedia implies they're straight up
ghosts so I I don't know how their
biology works I got nothing the night
sections are another grave reminder that
there's still much about this ecosystem
we don't understand
I found Footprints by the creek the last
time I went and well this made me feel
like a Tracker the truth is I don't know
what kind of animal they belong to I
feel the same way in Pikmin when I
encounter something like the Bermuda a
strange hairy creature that doesn't fit
with the other animals I've encountered
other than the fact it likes to plant
Pikmin I know nothing about its biology
or lineage
perhaps the final region has some
answers the primordial Thicket is a vast
undergrowth teeming with life more
dangerous than any other area dense
networks of fungi coat the forest floor
in thick clouds of spores can block
certain Pathways the tiny white Pikmin
can help thanks to their natural
immunity to the spores toxins indeed
these spores seem to be parasitic as
they've taken over the bodies of many
animals that live here and this at last
provides key potential insight into the
mysteries of Pikmin biology many of the
animals in this Forest seem to be a
combination of both fungus and animal in
some cases like that of the well
camouflaged startle Spore the fungal
parasite seemed to be an integral part
of their biology and the startle Spore
has a cousin in the form of the more
plant-like creeping chrysanthemum in
something about how the chrysanthemum
emerges from the ground seems awfully
familiar more on that in a moment
one species that seems immune to the
fungal network is The Towering grub
chucker these bipedal creatures snag
prey with a Long Reach of their pincers
and toss them into the mouth on top of
their heads the food is then digested
slowly a fate we want to avoid
we must also avoid cloudy water for the
bog swallow lies in weight possessing
six primitive eyes these creatures seem
to be a holdover from a forgotten
primeval age
yet the last new creature we'll visit
today is far more ancient it's a
sovereign Bowl backs the largest member
of the grub dog family these genuine
Titan snag food with their long sticky
tongues and can swallow up many unwary
Pikmin notably The Sovereign bowlbacks
cultivate a rich corporate of plant
matter on their backs that help them
stay camouflaged under the ground it's
another example of plant and animal
symbiosis that might finally let us
crack or big mystery
given all we've seen the pigment may be
hybrids of animals and plants
specifically parasitic plants like the
creeping chrysanthemum there's evidence
to support this as some explorers are
turned into plant hybrids after exposure
to an onion if this is correct Pikmin
have clearly evolved to become heavily
intertwined with their plant partners
indeed one in-game scientist proposes
that Pikmin are entirely plants and
evolved from root vegetables and while
this seems less likely as is often the
case with Pikmin it's impossible to say
for certain
though the time has come to leave this
particular World Behind it's worth
reflecting on our New Perspective in the
Mysteries that remain Pikmin isn't a
series that reveals all of its Secrets
like a child turning over rocks you'll
always be an interloper to some extent
an outsider making assumptions but it's
a series that makes you think more about
the ecosystems just below you and I've
left plenty of stones unturned and
creatures undocumented if you're
interested in exploring this world
yourself
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign